bonsoir kerviel colomé merci d'être avec
nous ce septième nuit consécutive donc
de manifestations en espagne comment
expliquer cette détermination des
manifestants
je vous dirai qui bon soir je dirais que
il ya trois segments de dons à dans le
groupe de manifestants il y a il y
aurait un parti politique anti système
qui est la coupe qui est en train de
faire entrer en négociation avec eux les
autres deux partis indépendantistes pour
entrer deuxièmement il y a des idées des
vandales des gens qui font directement
des éléments de deux contres
don de vandaliser de prendre des banques
comme on a vu des matchs et a été
ressenti par an étaient saccagés et
finalement le troisième groupe le plus
important c'est le groupe pg qui sont en
train de se manifester leur âge leur
indignation pour n'a pas savoir un futur
qui n'est pas possible en ce moment
c'est à dire c'est une génération qui a
vécu de toute chose très importante
c'est à dire une crise économique comme
en 1929 et maintenant une pandémie comme
la fameuse grippe espagnole de 1918
c'est à dire que cette génération que
très préparé mais n'ont aucun futur ils
sont tous dans son sang pouvoir voir
quel sera le prochain pas dans une
société qui est en train très grave
éléments d'économies et a pas de futur
ces jeunes c'est à dire ces trois
éléments qui se sont mis à côté de
l'autre mais voilà ça c'est le problème
et on renvoie précisément qui sont ces
manifestants pour qu'on comprenne pas ce
qu'on imagine peut-être que ça va au
delà de cette affaire pablo à celles qui
sont ils et qu'est-ce qui le voile
exprimé le premier groupe s'est il
exprime exprime pardon je dirais la
logique anarchiste anti autoritaire et
en triant y contre la police c'est en
plus un parti qui est en train de
négocier avec eux
le futur gouvernement une république 1
et 2 du parti de monsieur plus de monde
et qui sont en train de réclamer une
logique un modèle de police tout à fait
anti autoritaire c'est à dire un parti
anti système qui est contre la police
qui demande un nouveau modèle de police
au futur nouveau gouvernement
1er le premier segment premières
deuxièmes des groupes qu'on a connu en
dix neuf en 2019 quand après la sentence
du procès contre les dirigeants
indépendantistes qui ont si pendant
presque une semaine ont mis à feu et ont
saccagé la ville de barcelone il ça
c'est aussi les groupes vendent ali
qu'ils n'ont rien à voir avec les autres
et finalement le groupe majoritaire
c'est si ceux qui expriment
littéralement e set comment dirais-je ce
malaise
le malaise de ne pas avoir un futur
d'être une génération très préparé c'est
ces gens qui sont des gens qui déjeunent
qu'ils ont entre 19 20 ans et 35 ans
c'est les millennials etc
cette génération qui ne parvient pas à
se faire un espace un creux dans un
créneau dans l'économie ni dans la
société
en ce cas espagnol je crois que c'est un
problème au niveau européen et sûrement
mondial c'est une génération très
préparée qui n'a pas de possibilité de
voir par exemple l'un habite âge où on
va voir la voir un couple pouvoir vivre
ensemble pourquoi parce que ils ont
parfois ils n'arrivent pas à la fin du
moins avec ce qu'ils perçoivent comme
argent pour mettre le travail qu'ils
font qui sont pas de thé très grand
travail mais ils reçoivent pas beaucoup
d'argent
en tout cas les les artistes prennent
part à cette affaire 200 artistes
précisément dans le cinéaste reconnu l
modo var électeurs ravi bardem qui ont
signé une pétition pour la défense ont
également du rappeur et son et contre
son incarcération
est ce que c'est une affaire qui va
vraiment au delà de la politique c'est
une affaire qui va marquer un tournant
dans la société catalane s'est pas
tellement un tournant parce que c'est
pas la première fois qu'on vise c'est
les semaines ne qu'on dirait comment
dirais-je de la barcelone en feu on a
vécu ça des gens en octobre 2019 c'est
le même parti la coupe est scellé
jeunesse de ce parti s'appelle anne qui
profite la sentence du rappeur ou
d'autres éléments pour sortir et faire
c'est devant revendication constante
parce que ils ont un slogan c'est à dire
le la voie pacifique
on n'arrive à rien fait avec la voie
pacifique c'est à dire on va éliminer on
va se confronter contre l'êta à partir
de la violence c'est à dire si vous me
permettez
c'est comme si on revient à la barcelone
des années 20 la 1920 quand on appelait
cette ville la rose des cheveux parce
que l'anarchisme était très très
virulent et très fort ici c'est à dire
que voir cette ville brûlé c'est pas la
première fois dans les derniers cent
trente ans c'est à dire c'est pas
nouveau et c'est possible que ça
continue aujourd'hui et on aura un autre
une autre une autre
finalement ça s'arrêtera et jusqu'à la
prochaine où on sait pas quel sera le
motif pour que recommence cette mon
dirais-je c'est un l'indignation les
genres âge les jeunes en âge et qui
sortent pour protester pour différents
motifs congénies politiques ou
personnelles de sang à venir c'est à
dire que et finalement pour le laissions
les vendent à lesquin qui font ce qu'ils
font mais c'est pas la coupe c'est
vraiment ce qui nous construisent les
barrières et barricades
c'est pas les vandales et que les
vandales sont différents ils attaquent
directement mais la stratégie de la
coupe c'est la confrontation avec la
police est avec l'état l'état
autoritaire et répressif ça c'est le la
logique idéologique qui sont ans qui
pratique depuis beaucoup d'années
merci gabriel colomé professeur en
sciences politiques à l'université de
barcelone
merci à vous